big announcement gang the through the
roof tour is on sale right now grab the
squad and come out and see the boys
stand up comedy show you got me Kippy
debone Tommy C then we play little ay
with the crowd it's a good good time yes
our biggest tour to date we're super
excited we hope to see everybody again
we're going to Charlotte Nashville Tampa
Atlanta Providence New Haven Boston New
York Rochester Syracuse Albany Baltimore
Portland I ain't done yet Seattle
Vancouver New Orleans Houston Dallas Red
Bank New Jersey all tickets are
available at rug garbage.com getet on
gang we want to see you out there more
cities coming soon mhm welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is are you garbage oh it's
that little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
grp to be classy but they're just a big
old piece of trash trash trash trash I'm
your host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toies in the new edition she is over at
the dentist office trying to get her
hands on a tank for the weekend out look
out $5 a cup over at toies my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
international businessman and he's my
best pal in the whole wide world give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody
what up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you R viw
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
true to real cooking and obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com garbage gang you go over
there you get a bajillion hours worth of
bonus content mm love that money how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinary the old magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone mccuins Toby
McMullen everybody what up boys hey pal
I'm stoked we got a hilarious dude in
here all time guy watched him absolutely
rip the Comedy Jam down a an Austin a
little set pipes on this one got some
some vocals on over there doing a little
Eddy vet we like it gang the long hair
ain't lying we could be more excited to
have our incredibly and I mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time he is a very
funny very successful standup comedian
and actor and you might have seen him in
but not limited to you got Jimmy Kimmel
Live legit beat you got mascots Robot
Chicken underdeveloped live at Gotham
your mom's house Comedy Underground The
Joe Rogan Experience this is not
happening the degenerates laugh tracks
WTF with Mark Maron the Adam Corolla
show he has multiple standup specials
out including 2015's funs size 2016
daddy issues and he's got a brand new
special out right now streaming on vep
entitled starfish and he's on tour give
it up for the one the only Brad Williams
everybody let's go let's go you guys
talk really fast I'm have to keep up
okay are you garbage my wife is going to
be watching this just going like yes
just say yes he's garbage I need the
validation we do a lot of pre-show meth
before you get here no kidding yeah oh
my God okay I I got to kick my stutter
on the back burner and really figure out
how to keep up with y'all Focus just get
a cup of coffee let's go buddy thank you
so much for coming in man we wanted to
have you for a while yeah well I'm a
West Coast guy you guys are on the East
Coast but I'm doing a little East Coast
run doing some shows out here doing some
doing some appearances and uh uh honored
to be uh stopping by here uh uh passed
four uh fake Burberry bag salesmen on
the way here that's nice lot of
counterfeit Goods floating around this
neighborhood yeah you guys like pick up
something for the wife Ty it's legit I
might it's legit I'm making money now
baby got a nice Burberry scarf don't
don't don't look at the label don't look
be it just trust me Burberry yeah
Burberry it's two bees that's fine and
uh yeah this is I'm a West Coast guy
like I said so walking into the studio
where the door is like you got you got
to know a guy to find the door um it
doesn't look like an office door it
looks like the it looks like the
portaling place walking through the back
yeah they're right upstairs up yeah
exactly so it's I'm I'm getting The Full
Experience uh I have yet to uh almost be
hit by a car slam the hood and yell out
I'm in here I'm hoping that'll happen
but not the whole hit by a car thing
it's very dangerous 4 fo4 I don't think
they'll stop I I I I just think they'll
assume I'm a pigeon and then just we had
a deal yeah and just do the thumb Thum
and that's the end of Brad Jesus Christ
give us the backstory give us the origin
story of Brad Williams where you grow up
tell us the whole W Coast kid right W
Coast kid uh born and raised in Orange
County California what I didn't know
that yeah some people think I'm garbage
just based on that alone that's rich
people country isn't it it
is and that's the end of that quite the
flex all right yeah you know some there
there a lot of comics come up here and
say like oh I had a troubled childhood I
had a horrible I had a horrible child I
like this not
me get these so this is great yeah uh
what the folks do uh dad was a good a
good lawyer really defense attorney
defense attorney he he he kept him out
of jail uh who who what what kind of
clients was he uh was it like corporate
or like you know private private yeah
well like he was a he he was a public
defender for a while so that's just
whoever comes in and can't afford an
actual attorney they always make that
move don't they they they cash it out
and then they move to the private firm
yeah that's what happens when you work
for like you know you work for like the
S you know the [__] Stock Exchange as
like a regulatory person you go cash it
in at JP
Morgan give me my money yeah then you
start some firm with like four last
names in a row then all and all those
four guys are dead yeah so was he a it
was there was a Williams in it uh there
wasn't a Williams uh but so it was not a
Williams but he did he when the fence
come night exactly just work here that
you yeah when when when they raid the
place or when just grab a broom and act
like you're the janitor yeah when
they're when they're repping Harvey
Weinstein you don't want your last name
cled in like oh you know famed attorney
Pete Williams from the fame Law Firm Tom
and Simpson young CER and Williams
you're like a [__] [__] give you the
promotion right before you get busted I
had to make partner [__] yeah exactly so
yeah uh group in Orange County uh uh uh
played played a lot of golf growing up
uh really really golf kid lot of golf
hold on take a step back did your mom
work no so your dad's killing it dad's
killing it he's doing well Dad doing
well where are you playing this golf at
a country club private private course
look at this guy come on he's still got
the Hat what do you think I look like
the caddy I look like a caddy or the guy
that stands out in front of your
Philadelphia home holding the
ring the thing that always got run over
in Home Alone uhhuh yeah got back times
I'm actual size uh but yeah uh uh uh dad
dad was big on golf so I knew that in
order to hang out with Dad you got you
know you got to play golf so uh played a
lot of golf [__] how many times a week
we talking uh uh dad played here's the
thing if if I had a game or a thing on
Saturday he wasn't there that was not
there because he's Hitt a link that's
his game that's a good Rich Dad right
there now if if if it's Sunday all over
it he's there he's bringing a cheering
section of the He he'll he'll bring
snacks you know but but Saturday sorry
that's a standing tea time over at the
club to tell and then I got to get drunk
with the fellas I got to scramble to get
I got to hit on a waitress and a
beverage cart lady
whoa take it easy yes how nice of a of a
country club are we talking here uh it's
not where the Illuminati hangs out but
where it's the Illuminati accountant
hangs out so it's pretty good that's not
bad they got a pool all that [__] yeah
yeah they got a pool Country Club kid
okay I like like I said I'm not going to
be the Vanilla Ice Guy where I where I
come on here and be like he was hard
growing up in these Mean Streets orang
Count's pretty good Mean Streets of
lagona we were doing well what's up any
brothers or sisters yes got one sister
uh uh I'm I'm the black sheep of the
family as a comedian she's she she's
partner at a at an accounting firm no
[__] yeah so she's doing all right uh
she got into Stanford turned it down for
a full academic scholarship to USC damn
uh so yeah and then and then and then I
went to USC because I felt sorry for me
and they needed a diversity hire hey a
win's a win baby hey I got in the kids
in let's go that's don't say that on the
degree baby let's go oh if I had a
degree I dropped out do your parents
still live in the same house that you
grew up in uh mom just moved out not to
take the story a little dark but dad
passed away two years ago it's okay so
when so so in Dad passed mom didn't want
to be in the in in the house so uh
downgraded to a to a lovely small home
in Beach Seven bedro only something
small I can IM only seven in Huntington
Beach Huntington Beach all right yeah a
lot of angry white conservatives there
there you go that's our surroundings so
what we us we like to ask people what
the the name of the street was that they
grew up on it since no one lives there
tell us yucka yucka yucka lane or Avenue
yucka Avenue Kish Boulevard what's going
on they're they're yucka trees oh okay I
don't even know what a yucka tree is
that's how poor we are it's not what you
say when you see the street okay what
was that what was the house like uh big
house they call it triy level it's a
fancy word for three story uh uh uh yeah
there there there was one room as you
enter the front door you turn to your
right there's a room that's a very very
lovely living room was always very well
decorated my family and I called that
the Christmas room cuz that's the only
time we'd go in there really was just on
Christmas where that's where the tree
was that's where you that's where you
sat Christmas room yeah Christmas room
that East Wing is deep
man here's the thing though but then my
dad uh uh n like we we we were doing
well uh but in but in the summer first
of all we had to beg my dad to finally
get air conditioning in the house really
beg beg
when he finally did you could never run
that thing that [__] cost money that
[__] cost money damn so man no AC no AC
in Orange County in Orange County that's
crazy no Coastal breezes so I wasn't I
you know we weren't the richest family
richest family we did okay financially
comfortable but inside very
uncomfortable yeah we did just fine as
my fits as my dad always describes upper
middle class you know like so not middle
class not rich upper middle class what
was your car wh what was your dad
whipping around town did he drive that's
a status as as a defense attorney in
Orange County you got to be whipping I
ain't trusting you with the case if you
rolling at a Corolla yeah he had he had
a Benz for a while he had a red Lexus
for a while I love that red man that
screams I'll get you off if the price is
right R Lexus that's got judge payoff
for license plate give me a call
yeah yeah thankfully he wasn't those
billboard lawyers like there's they're
crazy the best now I'm fascinated and I
I don't know if this going to be a
premise for me but like every town I go
to has its billboard lawyer oh uh so I'm
in Los Angeles our billboard lawyer is
sweet James sweet
James and and that's that that's all the
Billboards you see it's on sweet James
baby I'll get you off yeah exactly but
every town has their billboard lawyer my
favorite one is uh uh uh they talked
about him on uh John Oliver show he's
he's a lawyer out in Texas he he's the
Texas Hammer he we've seen that guy
driving around Texas you want to be
repped by the hammer he holds a
sledgehammer in his commercial he's like
I'm the Texas hammer and he talks
exactly what like you want the Texas
Hammer to talk yeah we see him on the
highway it's always like when you
injured in a car
accident all Texas always has hit by a
truck question mark it's like what the
[__] what the hell's going on down here
call the
shovel are you in jail is there a wall
that goes to the outside call the Texas
Hammer you accidentally shoot your
buddy Tex Hammer accidentally said
quotes so I'm glad he wasn't the
billboard lawyer that's good a little
bit a little more cache than a billboard
lawyer all right uh you got into USC how
are the grades growing up they're pretty
good uh public school private school
public school okay so good Public School
P Public School drama theater nerd okay
so I was in all the now don't get me
wrong I played some sports okay what'
you get what you do hockey was my main
sport really loved hockey I was a
defenseman number 33 and uh uh I I love
I love doing that so played golf played
hockey was all was always involved in
theater uh uh hit me with a couple
Productions that you were in oh what
what do you want okay you want my
favorite one Oklahoma South Pacific
wasn't street car name desire I was in
How to Succeed In Business Without
Really Trying I was in the hell that
sounds like an infomercial that was that
sounds like something the Texas Hammer
saw the Texas Hammer how does get
Business Without Really Trying TR
translation is that a play it's a it's a
full musical okay I can s takes place in
the break room I oh there's a song
called coffee break but yeah there is
it's a good one that's my big solo yeah
uh uh uh uh no my big solo was uh
company way yeah I played it the company
way yeah that
one hit for copyright sounds like I'm
making it up I'm
not yeah little little little bit of
that little bit of anything goes a
little bit of little bit of hello Dolly
okay oh yeah I'll [__] song and dance
man over here I'll freaking do it all
I'll do all I'll do all the songs from
the from those plays and musicals but
the grades were good grades were good
got into USC uh like I said diversity
higher and uh then when I when when I
had one year to go that's when I
discovered standup comedy okay and uh
called the parents and was like
ah I'm not doing dropped out you dropped
out four com for Open Mic dropped ow
damn not for not for open mics okay I I
was starting doing open mics freshman
year okay okay okay so that's uh and
then got more serious and then so that's
2003 so I've been in the game 20 years
you're doing open mics in La yes okay
yeah first time ever was uh at the Laugh
Factory and now you guys are going to
love this uh so I'm so I'm I'm in line
you you sign up for the Open Mic at
about 1:00 not in the morning p.m. sure
but then uh the show isn't until 5: and
for a guy like me driving from Orange
County you got to find parking you got
to move your car cuz all the signs that
say 5 minute you know 30 minute for
between this hour and this hour on this
day with the [__] Mercury's in
retrograde it's just horrible trying to
park there uh but then there's a guy in
line and and he looks at me goes hey man
I haven't seen you around I go ah well
this is my very first time he goes ah
your very first time on stage I go yep
he goes well my name is burger and then
just don't worry just do whatever I do
you'll be fine I've been doing this Open
Mic for years I don't want to do that
I'm not I'm not doing what you do Burger
now not to be confused with hamburger
which a very famous very
successful standup comic but yeah burger
burger haven't heard from him since yeah
he ain't doing that well but yeah start
started doing standup and then in 2003
uh 2005 when I had like a year left to
go I had the opportunity to go out on
tour and like really make some money so
uh told told the parents ah I'll just
graduate later was that the plan would
you really going I'm going to go back or
you like never no one's going back I'm
asking he had the intention I don't know
never what was the major was it a film
and television major
Communications we did not lose a cancer
cure by me droing out it's not like when
Dr Ken goes I'm not going to be a doctor
anymore I'm going to be a full-time
actor comedian you're like Society is
all right with you pursuing we lost a
minor league baseball announcer that's a
good Gig if you get it that's not bad
and the Tacoma Bulldog should really use
it yeah I mean they could have had me
like the whole goal was to be a a a a
sports broadcaster broadcast journalist
simply no [__] because my dad said
you interviewing a basketball player
would be funny that's that's a good bit
that's a good bit and and sure enough
years later I got to uh through through
a radio station out in Los Angeles
called krock I got to work the red
carpet for one of the uh Laker kickoff
EV and I got to interview Pal Gasol and
Dwight Howard who are huge yeah godamn t
basically I I I interviewed their dicks
they had a lot to say how are you guys
doing especially Dwight's and uh yeah so
so yeah Dro dropped that of school with
a year to go to do standup comedy and uh
20 years later I'm promoting a special
on veps there you go all right so things
are going great shout out to it Kip
let's talk about Adam and Eve shove
something in you baby yeah gang
Valentine's Day is w rapidly approaching
and what better way to show your loved
one is that the right term loved one I
don't love
them that you love them is by sticking
something up your butthole yeah or stick
your wiener in something so do yourself
a favor get over there to Adam an eve
grab her a vibrator or grab one for
yourself I don't judge bup plugs
whatever you need they got it we love
Adam and Eve and it shows up in a nice
discreet package so the nosy neighbors
don't know what you're up to with the
boir a little bit of Hanky Panky H Adam
and Eve has been around for over 50
years they' they've been making you come
so you don't so you know you can trust
them to give you not only a great time
but a high quality product at the end of
the day you want to make sure what
you're putting inside you're putting
yourself inside is a is high quality
stuff here sure uh whether you're in you
saying wooden dildos or nothing like
that uh and you don't have to get too
super crazy if you're a beginner they
they got just something you can spice up
for your Valentine's Day uh and we got
an awesome deal for you here for R you
garbage listeners when you go to Adam
and eve.com and select almost any item
you'll get 50% off baby there you go uh
so head on over to Adam and eve.com and
that's not all you get to select your
one of them you'll also get free
shipping DDO there go over to Adam and
eve.com and make sure you use our offer
code garbage at the check out again
that's code garbage at Adam and eve.com
Happy Valentine's Day
everybody K let's talk about butcher box
shout out to the box of butcher baby OG
baby well been in a game with us for a
long time long time got my freezer
stocked full of meat we're not talking
about that crap you get at the grocery
store we're talking about wild caught
we're talking about grass-fed grass
finish beef we're talking about free
range chicken we're talking about the
good stuff do yourself a favor get over
to the butcher box they send you a bunch
of meat it shows up you throw it in the
freezer whenever you're ready to use it
you take it out you defrost it you got
top quality meat to serve your family
that's why it's baby it's fantastic they
were nice enough to send us I don't know
about 5500 lb came in on a pallet I got
so much ground beef I got a lot of
hamburger meat uh butcher box will even
send you guides tips hacks so you can
create so you can make the most of each
box uh so you're eating well and you're
saving tons of time and you'll always be
prepared with awesome cuts of meat in
your freezer ready to go whenever you
are here's the turkey baby hit them with
butcher box you don't have to worry
about what's for dinner butcher box is
offering are you garbage listeners their
choice of a weeknight meal essential now
here it is baby 3 lbs of chicken thighs
two pounds of ground beef or one pound
of Premium steak tips for free in every
order for a whole year yeah I love those
steak tips though they all right plus
you get 20% or I'm sorry you get 20
bucks off your first order sign up today
at butcherbox.com use the code ay to
choose for your free offer and get $20
off baby do it back at that age so or
like Teenage what was the first car your
first car first car was your dad hookies
up or you have to work for it was it it
was new don't get me wrong but it was a
it was a Toyota Tacoma that's a okay bad
truck yeah good
uh dad put one of those caps on the uh
on on the bed so it could go up and I
had you know so you could lock the bed
and you could secure things in there uh
uh yeah okay so yeah the was was a new
car so I did all right pickup truck with
the cab on it that's it's got a bunch of
fertilizer in it I don't like that at
all well that's so your friends don't
ask you to move that was literally why
he like put the cap on it so you can't
put a lot a lot of stuff on it that's
not bad yeah yeah yeah mentality I like
that what was the first job first job
all right uh uh uh okay first job was I
worked you know you know the mall store
Hot Topic of course you worked at Hot
Topic I worked at Hot Topic i w I walked
in there cuz I I listen to a lot of rock
music they had all the Rock t-shirts so
that no so I wasn't I dress pretty much
how I dress now sure like just you know
basball now that I'm looking at you I
can see you behind the counter Topic's
up dude so like Hot Topic it's all like
you guys get your ears pierced yeah it's
all the gauges the Goths the you got you
got pants that have chains on them and
and dyed hair and they just looked at
the little white dwarf from Orange
County and was like oh dwarf yeah that's
weird enough you can work here I'll fit
in yeah you can work here that's fine so
I I worked at Hot Topic and then and
then right after that I worked at
Disneyland Disneyland doing what uh I
was a bodyguard for the characters so I
walk around with Mickey Minnie Donald
you know uhhuh you know make sure
they're all right every now and then a
5-year-old steps out of line you got to
be like what's up [__] hit him with
yeah hit with a stone cold I talked to
you for a minute did it tasing kids in
Disneyland whoa Hot Topic in Disneyland
that child is 7 years old B man we took
a left turn from from a defense lawyer I
know County my ass yeah well you know
got you know they don't give you the
corner office to start sure you got to
work your way up but but but here's the
thing I've never really had a real job
like I had you know Hot Topic which was
fun you get to sell gauges to depressed
kids and then working at Disneyland
that's fun uh hell when I would go to
Disneyland living in Orange County as a
dwarf everyone just assumes I work there
anyway as well be getting paid for paid
for that that's a great that's a great
job to have when you're in high school
cuz you get to go to the park for
free in high school you were doing this
yeah and then well cuz I started stand
up at 19 sure so those those are my
three jobs jobs ever yeah all right yeah
so it was uh yeah so it's a Hot Topic
Disneyland and then standup comic very
briefly had a had a morning radio show
in San Francisco this is like eight
years ago what was the name of it uh uh
uh the the Kevin Klein Morning Show I I
I did not make the you weren't you
weren't top billing you w partner at the
I didn't make the header my dad my
sister me that's our that's our claim to
f f under the radar we get we get in the
door but we're not on the door what were
the uh the vacations like growing up
where would you guys go anywhere good
Hawaii I think a lot didn't go to Hawaii
till I was an adult really yeah but
that's what all rich La people but we
went to we went to some good places your
Lake tahos your Sun Valley Idaho but
then we started going on vacations to
wherever the the all right I got to tell
a story to tell a story here so
uh every summer when I was a kid I'd go
to the uh the national dwarf convention
and that's sounds like I'm ly as a kid
yeah as a kid so you go there I bet you
cleaned up dude as a teenager yes uh as
a teenager and as a young adult worked
Hot Topic I did I did all right I can
get I can give you a discount on a on a
Motorhead shirt yeah I did all right and
in terms of the world of little people
I'm pretty [__] goodlook okay this is
this is pretty handsome right here this
is pretty wow that's all right even
before the beard so uh yeah so every
summer I go to these little people
conventions which is over a thousand
dwarves go get going into one hotel in a
random city across our our the great
land of ours and uh and so our family
trip every year would be to that City so
if it was in San Antonio well then the
williamses are going to San Antonio and
we're going to go have a good time and
see whatever there is to see in that
City how long was the convention uh for
for a week for a week yeah yeah so we go
for about a week and they try try to
design these conventions like all right
it's for togetherness and you get to
talk to people and you know there's a
clothing exchange there's doctors
there's sporting events which by the way
are funny as [__] uh dwarf sporting
events you know you you you have eight
dwarves running track hilarious that's
yeah hilarious did you do any of the
events all of them I was cleaning up how
do you think I got all that I was
athletic I was like oh my God now I go
play basketball and they're like
Williams you're Center what yeah no one
knows how to rebound by the way
we just hold our hands out like this to
catch a rebound call him the skyscraper
yeah oh [__] I heard Williams is coming
this year we don't stand a chance I was
clanging and banging down in the hle you
know I was backing guys in uh but yeah
so it's they try to dress it up with all
these events but really the whole
convention's for banging it's for going
there and seeing a seeing a potential
partner and be like holy like the whole
year you're friend zoned and then you go
to the dwarf convention and you're hot
so uh yeah people would have quite a
week it's got to be [__] sick yeah it
was awesome LPA yeah LPA little people
of America there you go he's got yeah
you got a dwarf brother yep so he he and
I speak the lingo did you just snipe
that or did you guys talk about that no
no oh no no we talked about before the
show I was like what the [__] yeah I was
like he just looked at you and went
dwarf brother oh no that's one of the
things they can do oh yeah I was like
Dam psychic
link [__] you didn't know that [__] no
there's so is that true you just scared
the [__] out of me yeah my brother
texted me this morning you having brat
on he knew yeah he got the newsletter
okay all right it's fine it's so it's so
strange cuz uh we should have told K he
could read
mine I would have flipped the table I
would have been out I was so shocked so
you got a crush in your landlord
huh I forgot you were in the room when
we talked about Jesus Christ so it's
funny cuz uh my opening act is a great
comic uh he's got his own special on
YouTube uh his name is JB ball he's a
black guy and we have noticed that when
we're walking around like he could see
any black guy and and and there's a hey
what's up man how's it going like
there's no understanding same thing with
dwars we're out and about I see another
dwarf in the wild I'm like what's up man
you know the struggle two Jeeps drive by
each other thr thr yeah yeah all right
yeah yeah you don't yeah but for dwarves
it's the uh microwave that's pretty good
I'll give you that I love a good pun
pretty good why not uh okay huh pretty
clean so far what was the Super what was
the supermarket you guys went to growing
up uh Pavilions Pavilion yeah is that a
where do you think that would rank was
it like if you're was it is it like Aran
or whatever no aran's crazy it's not
aoan we weren't selling like it it's a
step above
Ralph's a step below Whole Foods I think
meaty part of the curve yeah I think
where it is like if you're on the west
coast it's on the same level as like a
Sprouts okay so it's like it's okaying
all right it's all right would you pack
your lunch or would you buy lunch at
school oh mom woke up in the morning and
packed the lunch every day what we talk
what are we talking oh horrible food
really Mom Mom couldn't cook no [__] she
didn't work that's all she was doing
what the hell was going on when I when I
tell people like my diet as a kid okay
like all right have you guys ever had
something called all right it's a Philly
so maybe chip chip beef on toast [__] on
a shingle yeah [__] on a shingle no [__]
about jerk yeah that's what we ate cuz
Mom didn't cook she didn't want to learn
dad you know she made chip beef on toast
yeah oh I love her you ever had grits
yeah what yeah of course love grits no
kidding love me some grits put some
butter and some B Grove in Mississippi
what the [__] all so funny story about
Mom [__] on a shingle and grits and AR
squirrel me yeah that's nuts mom uh was
B yeah mom was born and raised in uh
Savannah Georgia all moved out to LA or
a town called Arcadia when she was uh in
high school high school she came there
as they were studying the CI and as The
Story Goes they were studying the Civil
War it's her first day of school and
they go well so we're studying the Civil
War Susan you're new to the class can
you can can you tell us who won the
Civil War my mom just goes the South
jeez yeah that's what I'm coming from y
I probably had some family members there
on January 6
sure war is still going on Sir still
going on it ain't over till it's over
called the culture War I'm glad I'm glad
Nick Sabin out cuz he's from the north
he's a damn Yankee we don't by way I was
also in that musical uh Nick Sabin got a
musical the Nick sain Story you haven't
seen roll
TI that's not bad
give me give me 5050 pages I would go
see it in a second all right oh that
that that Miami Dolphin second act would
be killer pretty good oh my God how old
were you when you got your passport uh
oh that's funny uh uh 13 uh cuz I had to
go on a theater tour of uh England and
Scotland that's yeah I got to go over
there I was in a deer troop Fullerton
children's Repertory Theater not
bad there and uh did some shows for the
locals uh stayed which by which by the
way you ever like look back on [__] when
you were like when you were a kid what
adult is in England and Scotland going
oh well the kids from America are coming
to do a musical let's go see that yeah
how loose is your schedule that's your
entertainment there's no movie theater
no nothing nothing I mean they're in
Scotland you guys I mean it's a little
ways away from where we were but
you guys got the Edinburgh Festival been
going on for years go see those
performances but now you're like when's
the children's theater that's that's
when's that happening when are they
bringing the children yeah and then uh
and then and then on top of that we
stayed with a few families while we were
over there so just I never got that
that's always so weird even like
exchange students yeah so not me and my
family or me and an adult supervisor
yeah just me wait would would there
would they have kids that were in the
thing in the theater troop too they they
they they would always have kids that
were about the same age but they weren't
in the theater troop so it'd be me and
one other kid from the theater troop and
we would go and we'd stay with the
family which now I look back on it's
like a [__] that's a red flag yeah
that's crazy nothing ever happened to me
but I don't know if something did happen
I wouldn't be shocked yeah that's that's
wild maybe it's a repressed memory that
you know we that I that I can trigger by
looking at something but yeah for the
most part it was
okay can't go near fishing chips start
screaming I okay man every year during
the World Cup I hear the scream ah uh
shoes off in the house growing up no
shoes on in the house which is funny cuz
now uh my wife is Chinese and definitely
shoes off in off in the house off in the
house yeah shoes off in the house now
but uh yeah she was on in the house were
you allowed to eat in her room could you
have snacks in your room uh no no no
eating in the room how are the snacks at
the house was there chips and pretzels
yeah yeah yeah there was stuff like that
you know if if it could be bought and it
and it was pre-made it was there yeah
pop sugar cereal poptarts that kind of
stuff it was okay yeah sugar cereals the
Golden Grahams that was my favorite okay
uh I still love golden gr what about
with dinner what were you allowed to
have water milk soda juice mostly Mo
mostly milk and water okay nothing too
crazy that's pretty good yeah nothing
nice glass of milk to go with a bowl of
chip beef on a hot summer day with no
air conditioning people wonder why I
have an iron stomach yeah how you that's
all she cooked she didn't what would she
make for dinner give me a typical Mrs
Williams dinner typical dinner would be
like a chicken breast some steamed
broccoli which okay from the south so
you want to know what we put on our
broccoli syrup or something like that
mayonnaise like on top what on the side
and then you dip the broccoli in there
steamed broccoli and mayonnaise steamed
broccoli and mayonnaise God damn but
that's sucks crazy is it you're from the
south no is that just me were we just
trash Oh my God man I've never heard
that never could someone you never you
never had cow patty broccoli one of your
listeners please write me and tell me
that you have steamed broccoli and
mayonnaise it's your sister it's yeah
that that would probably be it that that
that would be just about it what was the
prefer sorry kiy what was the preferred
fruit snack in the house uh literally
fruit snacks like fruit no oh fruit
snacks like the wel isn't it Welches
fruit snack oh we wish we had Welches no
no we were no we were more gushers yeah
we were a gusher I think you ever met a
kid that grow up with regular gushers no
that's a treat every once in a while
they weren't there they they didn't do
it for me oh I love them there was not
enough of them that's candy that Ain
saying that's candy that's like a nice
shot of high fructose corn syrup to the
back of your mouth they were yeah who
doesn't love a gusher uh what was the uh
first of
all frozen pizza growing up Endor now oh
no uh Frozen but then we also would go
to the old school Pizza Huts that are
now kind of making a nostalgic come so
you a Pizza Hut family yeah Pizza Hut
gentle all right Pizza Hut what was the
frozen pizza the preferred frozen pizza
at the house uh b b yes that's the one
you kind of made yourself a little bit
Yeah man that's rich kid [__] B is a
frozen yeah okay I don't think it was
frozen I think it was sealed uh it was
like packaged it wasn't Frozen yes yeah
and it would be hanging on the end of
the aisle and it would come with this
little sauce packet so your mom cooked a
little bit she could put the pizza
together they they do both they do both
it originally I think in the 9s was
[__] just the isn't that weird I
never thought about that till just now
but like what a question what was your
frozen pizza short welcome to the show
every everyone had a brand I I didn't
realize I'm like oh we've never gotten B
never had really start calling you sir
kidding me my stepdad would buy it maybe
once a year when he was feel I guess
like tax tax return came in or something
he's got to impress you step really
throwing down try trying to get you to
call him dad and not
Mark whatever Mark o bubble
it thank you can I have another slice
Daddy thank you papa what was the first
concert you went to first concert I ever
went to was uh all right so this is a so
I was in a band for a second name of
that band here we go the name of the the
name of the band I was in and by way the
paint's coming off this house slowly I
was a hype man in the band so I didn't
play an instrument I didn't sing I would
do I would run I would run around the
stage and scream random lyrics try to
get the four people in the crowd going
had no musical talent but the band
thought a dwarf running around screaming
random lyrics that's pretty funny a Hot
Topic you were in the industry yeah got
him from Disney yeah exactly so uh the
name of our band was uh up syndrome
oh Jesus not down syndrome sure we're
not [__] holy [__] up syndrome okay
our big hit that we would close every
show with was the safe sex song uh and
then I would come out and do a little
rap at some point you know at the you
know the white guys from Orange County
that's a rap Haven where were you doing
these shows the Forum where would you
guys usually there was a there was a
there's a punk rock Club on the corner
of Harbor Boulevard in Lincoln called a
chain rea action and that's where all
the punk band came yeah yeah so it's
like all those bands like uh so it's
like New Found Glory Simple Plan yellow
cards all came out of there they all all
pass through they all told us we
stunk Goldfinger like uh it was so crazy
cuz I I just saw yellow card literally
like two nights ago and then my band up
syndrome did a show with them in Pomona
at a at a venue called the glass house
so now it's like wow well you guys did
way better than we
did and they cool to see you guys are
still together yeah they have a fiddle
player and they they they killed it so
yeah that's my that that's like my
Feelgood uh Pandora Spotify station you
throw on like New Found Glory all the
all the punk bands that sound like they
were holding their nose like all that
pop punk from the why I love you like
all those bands I love those bands but
they were they were you guys were all
coming up kind of at the same time when
you were playing that's pretty cool yeah
so yeah and and then I was like well I
have no musical Talent so uh let me try
comedy threw me out of the band
thankfully it worked I I think I think
you could find one of our music videos
online it was called it was for a song
called The Jackson Five hear people
Googling that now to the Jackson Five
were wrong I think I think that's
available online but back to the
question what was the first concert ah
first concert so that so I went to a
bunch of little shows like that that's
why I told that story so there's a bunch
of little punk shows like that I think
like like uh uh the the The Ataris was a
good show but then my first like big
concert was uh Pennywise and that was at
the Long Beach arena and I went to the
mosh pit I came out missing uh uh uh my
noia phone um my sidekick came out
missing a shoe and came out missing my
car keys and my dad had to come and
drive to the arena and then bring the
spare key so we could drive home man
that so yeah the where are your
shoes one shoe so the Pennywise mosh pit
that was a time bro him tribute Ah
that's a good that's a good song that's
not bad posters on the wall would
reflect the same musical taste I would
assume dude I met the this guy that was
on my wall my entire childhood it was so
crazy so uh last week uh uh I I I went I
went to Laker game shout shout out to J
Moore for uh Mo getting me the tickets
and I'm sitting there and the guy that
sits in the row in front of us the
Flopper himself Vlad deok no kid VL
shout out to the king I had a poster of
vlat and you can probably even look up
the poster because the poster goes viral
every now and then because in the poster
there's just a random Arm coming out of
VL and you don't know whose arm it
is you can't see the body you can't see
so it's just random arm and yeah I had a
poster of Vlad on my wall and uh man he
was like 44 playing in the
league was chain smoking on the bench he
was old school said he was
21 play I play with magic Johnson I tell
him where was he from
Serbia Yugoslavia something with an AIA
IDE the man I didn't I didn't think
about that J moris must be getting hit
up for tickets all the time yeah so J
Moore now married to the owner of the L
that's crazy crazy shout out to J Moore
yeah so uh uh yeah I ran into Genie bus
at a uh uh at a Total Wine uh about a
month ago and uh I was so I'm going
there doing some shopping and then she's
there she has a tequila and she's doing
like like an appearance I just I'm like
no it's j bus and and and she just
looked at me she goes you're friends
with my husband and I go yes I am and he
goes and she looks me she goes yeah I
follow you on Instagram I go I I I
figured whoever runs your account
follows me I didn't know that you and
she that's pretty sweet yeah this guy's
doing all right tell you that [__]
Genie bus is saying hey I you that's
crazy yeah um all right let's uh let's
switch it up to now childhood's [__]
bulletproof yeah childhood's pretty good
there's a couple of uh couple of cracks
in the foundation but who who don't have
that chip beef fun toast you call it you
call it ground beef or hamburger meat oh
Crown beef how do you feel about the
rotisserie chicken I'm a big fan of
rotisserie chicken all right good man do
people not like rotis chicken who are
these people I don't know depends how
big I guess everybody's a fan it's to
how often are you having them oh okay
okay okay like weekly okay so I'll I'll
say this because because my mom wasn't a
great cook there was a uh restaurant
that that we would go to like two
sometimes even three times in a week no
kid it was a sushi restaurant so I was
like raised on Sushi no [__] so uh I'm
throwing a little throwing a little
garbage there uh so yeah that's what you
mean that's classy trashy to go out to
dinner that much I get what you're
saying but Sushi I mean and very and
very nice so like yeah it it it was it
was good and it was a lot of fun and and
now like now that Sushi got trendy now
it's like some people are are just
learning about it ah amateurs yeah I was
having it I was having it in the crib
exactly been doing saki shots since I
was four you know what Saki Bomb is Brad
so you can use chopsticks I assume [__]
yeah how early could you use chopsticks
MH pretty early pretty early like yeah
like before the age of 10 for sure Jesus
I don't think I saw them before the age
of 10 yeah well now and now cuz my wife
is Chinese I'm getting like now I'm
getting my knowledge about Chinese food
which is really great and uh like the
good Chinese food I don't think I've
ever had it no but now now I'm learn
like there's I'm going to pronounce this
wrong so I apologize uh but my f but my
favorite thing is I believe it's called
xiaan ba and that's a dumpling that's
filled with hot soup oh soup dumpling
yeah xang ba yeah yeah soup amazing yeah
you got to get that if you don't know
about those got to get I know soup
dumplings what am I an [__] you don't
know soup
dumplings I don't like this coming here
and tell me I don't know soup dumping
crazy man I've done 400 episodes he just
got personally offended by you going
he's like think I don't know drag me in
here [__] like a piece of
[__] I didn't know the proper
terminology for it but I know soup
dumpling I called a number three in my
neighborhood comes with fried rice okay
yeah all right man eclectic gentleman
over here very eclectic let's say you go
out to dinner now uh will you and it's
someone's birthday will you tell the
waiter it's their birthday so they sing
happy birthday or no dude I'll dude I'll
do that if if it's not your birthday
Jesus I'm that guy but to embarrass you
not to get a free dessert gotcha cuz I
think there's an important distinction
yes if you're doing it for the free
cupcake it's a tough look you're an
[__] but if you're doing it because
as your friend hates when they come out
and sing to him now now now you're fun
and if you go out to dinner with the
squad now like you and and somebody else
will you guys split the check or will
one of you pick it up so the deal is is
I think either I'm paying or you you
just throw down credit cards and you say
split it you do not go itemized of
course never do that yeah you don't go
down there and be like well your glass
of wine was $2 more expensive than my
mixed B so no throw down the cards like
gentlemen split it up okay fine down the
middle and what's the house looking like
these days you guys you guys are in a
single family home uh yeah single family
home out out uh out in Southern
California we got
uh we got uh five bedrooms nice piece of
property got a pool no don't don't have
a pool had a pool growing up though uh
INR yeah INR defense attorney [__] Co
dud I'm not this I'm not this Baltimore
Ryan above ground pool
[__] outy did you guys have a diving
board yeah had a diving board had a wasp
nest under the diving board that's they
come standard issue which we never got
rid of money can't buy everything no cuz
we got well we got rid of it one time
and then it just came back so we're like
well it's part of the diving board so
there was always like always so you
always swam in the shallow in and then
every now then you go into the deep it
but you hey was Nest just so you know
like oh
man with attention so you had to really
be dedicated if you're like I'm going to
jump off the diving board you're like
okay had to be quick you couldn't do a
practice job you can't stand up there
and think about it no you got to hit it
and
go all right you got the five bedroom
the shoes are off in the house if we
came over to the house right now yes uh
and you offered us a glass of water what
would we be getting would we be getting
tap would we be getting filter so brda
You' be getting from the fridge okay
from the
like but we have water in the house but
I I
ass damn you are rich like we have
bottles and we have uh uh uh I don't
know if they're a sponsor so I don't
know if them but liquid death are very
kind to me I really like them and so we
got a bunch of those cans so I I I would
probably say hey do you want it from the
fridge or you get a glass of water we
can give you these cans spark or
whatever front can of liquid death you
got a fridge in the uh in the garage yes
and that's where the where you keep the
waters and the sodas and stuff like that
so we got a fridge in the garage uh two
fridges in the kitchen the the food
fridge and the drink fridge really yeah
wait two fridges in the kitchen in the
kitchen yeah wait hold on the fridge in
the kitchen is it you open it like that
that that's the and then in the island
there there's like a little like a wine
like a wine fridge but just for drinks
and then and then is and then I and then
I got a man cave where uh I got a drink
fridge in there what's in there are you
a boozer you on the hooch oh yeah love
me some whiskey love me some Scotch okay
didn't think I was a scotch guy thought
thought I hated Scotch then I met my
wife she's a scotch woman and turn turn
turns out I was just drinking really
shitty Scotch really cuz she introduced
me to like good scotch oh good scotch is
good not not a big Scotch guy oh you got
have some good [__] I'm a I like a Dr
Pepper
on the
Rocks clad so that's three fridges I'm
counting no that's four four four four
four fridges my uh a record my wife got
me this thing that's uh like you do you
ever go you ever go to the website Touch
Of Modern it's like this weird weird
fancy [__] she she got me this I I
didn't know where you were going with
that for a second yeah well anytime you
say you ever go to this website and then
starts with t lot of things can be
happening so uh there's a coffee table
in there and the coffee table is a
coffee table that's also a drink fridge
you got to be a member to get on this
thing that is also uh a giant Bluetooth
speaker so that's in my man cave so
that's that's pretty good that's pretty
trashy too but I like it oh it's fun
what's on the walls in that cave oh a
lot of sports
memorabilia uh so my two big pieces are
ass signed uh lway Jersey John laway
Jersey I'm a huge Broncos fan and then I
got a helmet uh that's signed uh Broncos
helmet that's signed by every Super Bowl
MVP so that's Von Miller uh Char Davis
John Elway then I got a a a poster uh a
signed plaque from uh Bobby or that that
was a good one too love love me some
Bobby or love me some sports memorabilia
how are you how are you acquiring these
things are they gifts are you searching
them out are you bidding on them I'm not
bidding I'm just going like so like when
I'm in Vegas they have that like sports
mobilia stores that are in the walkin
malls I'll just go in and every now and
then I'll see some I'm like that that's
it that's great what's the most you ever
paid for one 2,000 two G's that's not
crazy that's not crazy that and that was
you know what that was when I shot my
Netflix was R cutting Ham's
mouthpie i w in the special this is this
is how cool my wife is uh when I got my
Netflix special we were shooting it in
Vegas it's uh called the Degen
bunch of comics are on it so you can go
watch it if you want uh we were shooting
in Vegas and we were walking around the
mall like the day before the taping and
we saw this sporting good store and then
it it was the helmet that's signed by
the three uh Super Bowl MVPs and it's
2,000 bucks and my wife is like get it
you got a freaking Netflix special sure
get the helmet I was like [__] yeah lady
I like you all a little cash down yeah
that was fun that's good speaking of uh
through any point in your career like
maybe first big paycheck or first
whatever has there any been any really
stupid
purchase no you never like looked back
and was like I shouldn't have [__]
done that that was I didn't need are you
good with money or you Reckless I'm
pretty good with money I I'm kind of
like my dad where it's like you have it
but you don't spend a lot of it you just
kind of you have air conditioning in
your house I got air conditioning got
the AC [__] yeah I got air conditioning
what kind of watch you got there that's
a nice time piece this is a I love
watching he takes it off that's that's a
gentleman's move right there Bova Bova
yeah biva I'm probably pronouncing that
wrong yeah boliva but you're you're ALS
you're also talking to the guy that
thought for until like the age of 30 I
thought Pudo was pronounced Pro
proso so I'll do the pr mosquito and
cheese please my cousin was real proso
in high school proso listen on that I
was at a damn I was at a damn delis I
was at a damn deli with a friend and I
and I order the pro mosquito sandwich
and there's not even an m in and he just
looks at me and starts laughing his he
goes That's a good bit I go what what
are you talking about I just say thought
you were
riffing huh okay yeah just ju ju just
assume I pronounce everything
incorrectly huh have you ever been
really into Harry Potter no no no no
okay never Harry Potter collect anything
growing up anything like uh beanie
babies or anything like that no just
like baseball cards and stuff like that
okay I was I I've always dug sports
memorabilia uh uh no didn't really
collect any of those Trends uh you're a
wrestling guy right yeah have you ever
taken a sign to a wrestling event no
I've not taken a sign to a wrestling
event and I did yeah you did I forget
what it said I was in fifth grade it was
uh uh what was the WCW Monday night show
uh Nitro it was Nitro I went to Nitro
okay okay and
uh I didn't but the one favorite one I
ever saw was who who was who was your
wrestlers in Nitro give me a give give
me I think this one this this was
probably the NWO years so it was that
you know those guys um Nash Hall Hogan
yes yes for sure bad Hogan yeah heel
Hogan he Hogan Blackbeard Hogan yeah by
the way did you see the story that came
out today that Hogan like helped someone
on the side of the road in Florida some
lady flipped her car and like and like
Hogan maybe like helped get her out any
wearing an elbow dropped leg dropped the
car he's wearing an NWO shirt as he does
it that's awesome could you imagine
that's a PR state of mind you're in
where's the camera brother I got you
brother it'd be cool if Hogan did that
and he had regular clothes on but before
he jumped into action he ripped
everything off he doesn't come out to
his music
CU he's coming out there oh yeah no
there was a great one it was it was a it
was WWF uh Monday Night Raw and the
cameraman wanted to show the sign but
knew he probably couldn't so he showed
like this sign and this was in the and
it just said Vince is a
queef dude we were in fifth grade we all
went to school the next morning did you
see the [__] queef dude the signs
there there there's some good ones back
in the day there there there's good ones
now there there's there's funny people
out there oh it's internet's the
funniest place in the world I like it
are you a Cologne guy he is I smelled it
in the bathroom Aqua Aqua Deo or
something uh Polo black polo polo black
polo black Is My Cologne it's been my
cologne since high school really yeah
it's just some what are you spritzing
how give me the method I do uh Spritz
Spritz just a that's it two neck nothing
on the wrists sometimes I'll he a French
[__] sometimes I'll I do the wrist
sometimes I'll do sprit Spritz and then
this is trashy I'll I'll take my wrist
I'll just wipe the neck I don't I don't
know if anyone else does that saving
money yeah yeah you are like your father
yeah exactly huh classy but trashy
that's me okay
[Music]
mhm how you TSA pre-check [__] yeah I
travel every week dude yeah you clear
too not clear as well stinks I I I don't
know see now a pre-check I was just at I
was just at LAX and literally the the
pre-check line was longer than the
checkin line I'm like damn it starting
to even out a little bit Yeah and I
don't like it cuz but then I got I got
to stay in the pre-check line cuz I
don't want to take my shoes off
so yeah so I stayed I stayed in the
PreCheck line flying up front uh when I
get upgraded okay I don't buy first
class tickets but thankfully I get
upgraded a lot I fly a lot so who you
flying American American fly American
through Dallas you and Foley have very
different flying experiences that's very
true though cuz I don't like when I
don't get upgraded I don't mind it cuz
it's like coach seat I'm fine chilling I
throw a fit in the airport I bet you do
a goddamn veteran for Christ's sake he
starts yelling bomb in the terminal real
quick clear him out now all right now I
I I don't know if this is a garbage
thing uh I did this one time uh they
said uh they did that thing where it's
like anyone with the anyone requiring a
little assistance to get on the plane
I've been debating starting doing or a
little extra time and this dude stood up
fine yeah I've seen that where you but
you can't ask what the [__] wrong with
you they can't say anything they need a
boun airline can't ask yeah I've asked
what' you say one
time I was like I I just looked at the
guy and I was like come on man they said
disabilities and this is real brutal
this is now in my act because it's a
true it's a true story the guy kind of
looks at me insulted and he shows me his
hand his hand is missing half of a
finger
hey I want to tell you well a goddamn
hero thank you for your service [__]
damn half of a finger I've been starting
to thinking about doing that a little
bit you just want to get your burger I
was going to get in there yeah get
situated and settled they can't C drink
yeah they can't they're not allowed to
say anything not allowed to ask yeah so
yeah when they say disabled boarding and
and yeah some people get up and I'm cuz
I don't board with disabled because I'm
I have pride okay okay cuz I I don't
like to view myself as disabled unless
I'm parking uh respect that yeah I got
the handicapped parking plot you do yeah
I'll use the [__] out of that I'll use
the [__] out
of dude kids work in the system oh my
God are you kidding she's going to get
into the
nightclub excuse me excuse me oh well
that and like I said the parking
situation in La very similar to New York
where it's just like it's crazy so with
the handicap parking placard here's
things that that people don't know you
can park at a meter don't have to pay no
[__] no [__] fck at you you park at a 1
hour parking take as much time as you
want no kidding handicap parking oh it's
the way of the future got the angles
will you bring food on the plane uh
literally only one time have I ever done
that okay I I don't bring food on the
plane I I don't know why I just I should
but I don't do you eat the meal if they
get if they serve a meal [__] yeah yeah
shoes off on the plane uh yes seat back
no okay never and th this I was so mad
on the flight out here because a lady
threw the seat back now if if you throw
your seat back in coach and you're
sleeping all right or if you're larger
you need some room all right I don't put
it back maybe a little but like this
woman threw a seat back but then didn't
go to sleep and was just watching a
movie the whole time you can't do that
[__] off age I wanted to say always said
the throwback is the uh egregiousness of
it you should do like a
little give a back give a look back yeah
yeah you're not even there yeah and like
I had a bottle like that that was up
that that like got like went flying when
she threw that Fe back cuz it was just
like like and through back you're a
classless individual that right if if
that's what you're doing I will judge if
somebody has a booger or bad breath will
you give them a heads up absolutely
anybody
not anybody friends okay but so what if
uh when we first met you at moon tower
yeah didn't know each other yeah but you
saw that I was standing there night a
boogie would you say hey man just a oh
comics yeah yeah you give me a heads up
yeah yeah Comics there's a mutual
respect course gentlemen excuse me sir
you have a booger nice to meet you nice
to meet you I'll do that a th% brad how
you doing I'm Henry great to meet you
man uh what's your favorite flavor of
Gatorade uh lemon lime okay old school
I'm I'm basic what's the credit score
like really good has it always been good
always been have you always been a saver
yeah always been good my dad always told
me he goes if you use the credit card
you know you you unless you have to you
pay you pay you off pay it off pay it
off don't ever be like oh throwing 40
bucks this month but like if you have to
you know you have to yeah if you're
trying to if keeping the plate spin a
little bit for sure yeah to totally get
that but if but if you got the means
always just pay it off so yeah I got a
good credit score and what cards are you
throwing around these days you got an
AMX uh no I got a I I got a business
card for my LLC sure which is nice who's
that uh that's just Bank of America
MasterCard okay uh but then I got a uh
just a Chase I I I don't really do fancy
credit cards no American Express no oo
don't do that okay not bad you own an
air
fryer my wife does yeah I mean so I
guess I
do I don't know what she does over there
really Tred to distance yourself on that
yeah she uses it I I'm like my mom I
can't cook wor [__] I found a a great
woman that can cook like hell and it's
awesome baking soda in the fridge yeah
freezer
too no okay are you currently any beef
with a neighbor yes really L
on we just moved into this house so you
know things been going good the past few
years so moved into a nice house really
happy about it uh uh within the first
week our neighbor who uh we were told by
a friend is a is is a heart surgeon so
we're like oh we got a heart surgeon
next to us hell yeah that's great and
then we get there we're doing a little
bit of work on the house our neighbor
called the cops on us Jesus because
there's an ordinance in our city where
you can't have outside work being done
after 3:00 or something it's some
obscure law afternoon yeah no one knows
about it yeah so it's 4:00 our work we I
got we got some workers still out there
and off dude calls the cops [__] that
and the cops even walk up and they're
like uh I mean we have to tell you to
you can't do this cut it out but holy
[__] like the cops are even like dude
this is f you just moved in yeah had you
met had you met the guy no that's how
that's comes over knocks or a call or
that gu going to be a problem heads up
literally literally on the way over here
we haven't had too much issue with him
[__] but on the way over here I got a
friend of mine uh he's a fellow comedian
uh Dave Williamson uh Dave Meet Dave
love Dave great guy so I'm in his
neighborhood and uh he knows my neighbor
he knows the guy yeah he knows the guy
so over there and barbecue him or
something he liter he literally just
texted me on the way over here he's like
hey your neighbor just asked for your
cell phone number before I give it I
figur I would ask you I go absolutely
not do not give this man my cell phone
number if he's got a problem [__]
knock on the door and talk to me like a
gentl I kind of respect that you move
into the neighborhood you're there
you're there whatever you haven't met
the guy yet I could see I mean you're
still a dick but I could see coming over
knocking on the door hey just so you
know there's an ordinance that you can't
do it after 3 you could even spin my
wife taking a nap I would spin it as
like hey man I don't really care about
the people around here you care can do
it's not me the [__] cops on you cops
some Nar ass [__] Jesus yeah like like
they got nothing else to do cops and
then goes crawling for your number what
how long ago was this what it cops
called this was 3 months ago so he's got
something else looking for your number
now he's now he's now now he's going to
text me now my wife now my my wife kind
of likes little trinkets on the front
yard I I think it's funny but now that
she knows that that and this guy's yard
is imaculate just this Immaculate yard I
think I I I I think my wife is putting
extra [__] on our front yard now because
piss him off what do you think he's want
your number for say sorry or you think
it's something else no Way's saying
sorry after nobody wants to say sorry
after three months if their first move
is the cops that's crazy n so he so he's
definitely got something else probably
probably the probably the flamingos on
the front yard flamingos yeah my wife
loves those little plastic flamingos she
loves them she think now I'm on the herd
shirts inside yeah uh I mean I I don't
have much left I he's pretty bulletproof
he's pretty bulletproof man couple
couple of cracks but you know what do
you give it a wedding let's say uh I
don't know a cousin's getting married a
niece a nephew uh now let let's say you
had a okay yeah cuz like which stage of
my life sure yeah now you're going to a
wedding next there was times and it's
like all right well I'm going to go to
the Sizzler and grab the napkins and
give those I'll do 10 minutes up front I
said I would do crowd work my gift to
you uh no but now yeah you go for like
between1 $150 somewhere like that yeah I
think so that and it's like expecting a
little
more be honest living next to a Goddamn
surge do do you ever have that thing a
strike for that yeah do you ever have
that thing where you go out and uh and
then the the waiter or the cashier
recognizes you and you're like o I got
to tip big now yeah for sure it's only
happened a couple of times yeah but now
we're pretty dumb with that anyway d i
we like to go heavy yeah you know your
dad was like Bully you know pay off the
credit card it's like I've never done
that yeah I'm an absolute standard 20%
bare minimum Tipper okay absolute
standard but then uh if if if you're a
weer and you're like oh I love your
comedy Brad Williams whatever I'm like
all right
21% it's 21 and a half and I ain't going
over I'm going to have to do some extra
cameos this week oh my God find me on
Cameo he's a little tight with the cash
a little tight with the cash with the
cash got to save up for all those
[__] football helmets say hey I got a
daughter she got to go to college Al
although she's Asian and a dwarf so
we're going to get a scholarship let's
be honest ever been bitten by a dog yes
okay few times uh Dalmatian oh they're
nasty right Dal are nasty Dalmation and
and then yeah so in uh I I I don't think
it was my fault it was me just petting
the dog and everything's good and then
you know dog goes and uh yeah when d
bites a dwarf that's not even a fair
fight like I can't even stand up for
myself but now now I got oh it's the
best I got this 80 lb Pitbull now yeah
and I walk that dog around the
neighborhood and everyone's like holy
[__] there's a [__] walking out
Pitbull holy [__] it's awesome people
cross the street oh it's [__] great
everyone every I don't know if I trust
that either as you're walking by you owe
it to yourself everyone own a pit bull
it's [__] great I got a Pit Bull mix
yeah yeah you own binoculars do not okay
do not own binoculars you like
pistachios although I I shout out to the
fans uh there were I I was going to show
a couple weeks ago and they sat in the
front row and then as a joke they pulled
out binoculars cuz I'm so small I'm like
I'm like good bit I like that two pairs
too was good synchronized anyway what
was that pistachios yeah red
ones I don't think they're banging
anymore that was a 9s thing didn't even
know what didn't even what red pistachio
they're green they're for Hillbillies
they D them red you did come for money
okay I only knew green pistachios uh in
the past 30 days have you been in a TJ
Maxx or a Marshals no but I haven't been
okay I as clothes shopping for a dwarf
isn't fun yeah it's just a lot of nope
uhhuh do you eat in the car [__] yeah
what kind of car you driving around Ina
oh Lexus now I do red no like d you buy
did you buy it new or is it least oh it
it's least but only yeah I'm I had I had
a blue Lexus before that just I drove it
over 100,000 miles fin finally got to
the end of it I don't like to lease cars
I like to own my car and uh uh but I
leased this one because I'm getting
ready to adjust the house so for an
electric car so I'm just going to lease
the hybrid all right you're doing some
work at the house you're getting
electric pretty c yeah man I got uh what
man is using at the house are you using
Helman Best Foods best best foods okay
Helman yeah okay I mean [__] bullet
that you know he's bullet stunned yeah
Brad Williams 100% class everybody
really you believe that T-Bone what
truly shocked shocked I'm shocked I
thought I mean the broccoli and the Mayo
but little thing you know that's a
that's cure and you just happen to get
your you know I'm I'm very um
sympathetic to the chiy fonto it's
literally one of my favorite foods shout
out to Gem restaurant dude I was at I
was at a restaurant that had it oh
Philly it's it's on every breakfast
every if it's there I will I will order
it I don't like I don't like classy corn
beef hash no me either get your classy
corn beef hash the [__] out of here
little tiny cubed potatoes burnt yeah
get it burnt meat that you're not quite
sure what or where it's from or whatever
give give me the Trashy corn beef hash
any day of the week man uh yeah yeah
some people do like fancy like shredded
corn beef or like pulled corn beef it
never it never comes together well no no
it's weird yeah so uh yeah yeah chippy
fontos I shocked uh I mean listening to
this podcast I was I was going oh man
I'm going to be garbage for sure no you
can't I mean grew up golfing what are
you talking about I know but even
outside of that maybe like you know we
we have a pretty good gauge of moving
the questions as we as you start
answering them to try to get you but I
mean you were [__] you're able to Bob
when we weaved hey man and like I said I
had no idea about the pizza now now now
I feel like this B yeah boy I mean what
are we talking about now I feel like
this is a new personality trade question
I asked what was your frozen pizza and
you gave me [__] not frozen pizza
like I feel like this has to be on every
personality questionnaire the wonderling
test put it on your dating profile NASA
they ask that yeah what was your frozen
pizza if you say if you get Boby they do
a credit check at the yeah for sure can
only pay by check yeah exactly they yeah
they know clear but I'm honored thank
you bu so much fun I'm honored to know
that I am not garbage classy yeah classy
gentleman one of a very few my friend
yeah you're in an Elite Class yeah who
else is on this list dud you
know Mr sagora sagora is classy I'll
take I I'll I'll Jared fre Ellis oh
Whitney Cummings when you said Whitney
Whitney might have been trash well she
came from Virginia I know so uh might
think she might have been I forget off
the top of my head can't remember yeah
but uh when when you said Jared I'm like
do not say from Subway do not do not say
that Jarry I don't want to be in any
category with that [__] how old do you
think the podcast is I don't know yeah
we would have had him free free or free
prosecution I mean old enough to date
Jared gang he's on tour right now in the
brand new special starfish is available
to stream over there at V do yourself a
favor check him out he's one of the
funniest one of the best Brad anything
else you want the folks out there to
know website social yeah just Brad
williamsc com.com has all the tour dates
so go so go there over 70 uh cities uh
coming up in in this next year kids
moving we're doing a lot man so uh and
we haven't even announced the uh
overseas tour yet which will happen soon
so if you're watching this in Australia
or in the UK get ready I'm going to be
coming out there in 2024 and Brad
Williams comic on Instagram that's my
most active social media we love it such
a fun time kiy what do you got for him
uh tickets for uh Town Hall New York
City are available on rug garbage.com
get those TI Town Hall New York City
Town Hall New York I'm playing there in
July
at leave a message for me on the wall
real low real low I gotta be able to
read it okay town hall and grab the areu
garbage card game over at rug
garbage.com it's our second edition of
uh 50 questions to find out if your
family and your friends are trash we
love you and we'll see you next week
peace